[MUSIC PLAYING]
CHRIS TALBOTT: Now I
imagine you're here
this week to talk about
what's going on in the cloud.
But I hope while
you're here, you're
still considering making
smart use of the resources
down here on Earth.
I'm personally a big
fan of our planet.
And I can't believe I'm
actually going to say this.
Even though there's a NASA
display about 50 yards that way
about finding the next
planet with life on it,
we need to consider
that we're going
to be here for a little while.
So even though our cloud
is not white or fluffy
and unpredictable moisture
is usually a bad thing,
it has real impact here
on Earth, the resources
that we use.
So this session today is all
about focusing on a commitment
to the environment.
What does it mean to
prioritize sustainability
as we make decisions
as IT practitioners,
as we set goals for
our organizations,
and ultimately in the products
that we design and develop?
You're going to hear
from three companies that
care a lot about the smart
use of the Earth's resources.
My name's Chris Talbott.
I work working at Google Cloud.
I work with customers
across the globe,
helping them understand
how a move to the cloud
can help them become
more sustainable.
And I'll share some
of that experience
and why Google Cloud is
a sustainable platform.
But I'm honestly excited about
what my friends are going
to share about a company
that is literally
an icon for
environmental stewardship
and how do they incorporate
that into their organization
and then a solar company
who is effectively
using cloud technology
to make renewable energy
accessible for all.
So let's get right into it.
At Google, similar to our
mission of making information
universally
accessible and useful,
we also have a mission to build
sustainability into everything
that we do as a company.
And breaking down what does
sustainability built in mean,
it means from hardware, to
the offices that we build,
to the data centers
that we build,
we're going to
prioritize sustainability
in that value chain.
That could mean incorporating
as much as 75% post consumer
recycle plastics in our
hardware to focusing
on buying ugly
produce in our cafes,
buying all the funny looking
fruits and vegetables that
would otherwise not be purchased
by restaurants and food
providers.
But I'm going to
focus on the two areas
that are probably
most impactful for you
as a cloud user or a
potential cloud user,
and that's data centers
and renewable energy.
And within these
two areas, we've
really taken that
sustainability mission to heart
by innovating and
building more technology
back into our
environmental practices
to effectively make
them more sustainable.
By pushing our
innovation upstream,
you as a user downstream
get a better experience.
So I'll take a
second to highlight
some of those areas,
essentially, the stuff that
can only get from Google Cloud.
First, data centers are at
the heart of our company
in everything that we do.
It powers Google
Cloud Platform, it
powers all of the
other Google products
that billions of users
throughout the world use.
And this is really
the critical part
of the sustainability
story for you as a user,
because all of us are
increasingly going digital.
And digital transformation isn't
about just using new technology
stuff.
It's honestly about betting your
business on a digital future.
And ultimately, you're
going to use more technology
stuff, which means more data
center use and more energy.
And with 2% or more of
the world's electricity
already going to data centers,
this is only going to grow.
But it's actually one
area where innovation
can have an incredible impact.
Compared to five
years ago, we actually
deliver seven times the
compute per watt of energy
that we use in our data centers.
Google Cloud's actually the
best at getting the most
out of the energy that we draw.
The way that you measure
this is something
called power usage
effectiveness or PUE.
It's calculated by taking
the total energy that you
use in your data center and
dividing that by only the stuff
that you use to actually
provide computing power.
For every watt of energy that
you use, how much are you're
going to have to use
for all the other stuff,
like facilities and cooling and
all the things that make a data
center work?
For us, we only need 11%
extra stuff to do that.
So it comes down to an average
PUE across our fleet of 1.11.
And you as a user of Google
Cloud products and services,
you get to take
advantage of that.
That's 50% better than the
average data center out there.
And that's efficiency
that we deliver to you
in using our services.
And one of the ways we're able
to achieve that efficiency
is we actually use
our own machine
learning technologies
in our data centers.
When it comes to
controlling a data center,
it's actually a really
complicated and unique beast.
There's millions
of components that
are relatively fickle
to unpredictable changes
in the environment.
So when you're
managing a data center,
trying to manage these
components in a very manual way
is really inefficient.
And kind of out of
the box manufacturing
or control systems,
industrial control systems,
they aren't universally
applicable across the data
center.
So when you're
facing a challenge
of trying to get better at
predicting unpredictable things
from millions of
inputs, neural networks
can do a really good
job at doing that.
That's what they're designed
to do-- essentially, learn
from millions of
inputs and get better
about predicting the future.
So our machine learning
actually controls the cooling,
which is a major part of the
energy draw within a data
center across our fleet.
I mentioned the other area being
renewable energy and energy
in general that's critical to
you as a user of Google Cloud.
Running our business
across Google
requires us to use a
lot of electricity.
And combating climate
change requires all of us
to transition to a
clean energy future.
So at Google, we match
every unit of electricity
that we use across our company
with a unit of renewable energy
that we've purchased somewhere
from a zero carbon source.
In pursuing this goal to reach
a 100% match of our energy,
we became the largest corporate
purchaser of renewable energy
in history.
And some of that investment
in renewable energy
actually goes to wind power.
And similar to our
data centers, we
found ways to make unique
use of the Google technology
to help make wind
power more valuable.
So the thing with
renewable energy
is it has to make
financial sense too.
That 100% match that
I just showed you,
it represents over $5 billion
in investment from Google.
And in order to make financial
sense, the energy that we use,
it has to be more predictable
to be more valuable to the grid.
Energy that you can't
predict is actually
less valuable than energy
that you can get consistently
contributing to the grid.
So we apply the ML
to our wind farms
to predict how they're
going to produce energy
36 hours in advance.
And this machine
learning algorithm
was essentially trained
on weather forecasts.
And by integrating this
into our wind farms,
we're actually able to increase
the value of the wind energy
that we're producing by 20%.
So with Google working
to make renewable energy
a viable and cost effective
source for our operations,
you as a user get that benefit--
the benefit, essentially,
of being carbon neutral.
So any organization that moves
infrastructure or applications
to Google Cloud Platform, you
reduce the net carbon emissions
associated with your usage to 0.
Everything that runs in our
Cloud is net carbon free.
I know I just said the
same thing three times,
but I want to get
this point across.
It's critically important.
If your organization sets
any sort of emissions
or sustainability
goals, this is the part
that enables you, as a developer
or an IT infrastructure person,
to participate in
that goal setting
and to actually be a
champion for sustainability
and a champion for change
within your organization.
Ultimately, we at Google
invest in sustainability
to empower all of you--
organizations, governments,
nonprofits, individuals--
to use the technology
in our cloud
and our other
applications to create
a more sustainable world.
One part is the platform,
Google Cloud Platform,
available to you to build on.
We really believe that
in addition to price
and high performance and
reliability of our systems,
you should get sustainability
built into the platform
that you use.
One of the other
ways we're really
focused on empowering you as
customers is through data.
We all know information that can
help us make better decisions
about our future.
So lots of the other
teams throughout Google,
the Geo team in
particular, works
with research and
environmental organizations
to get the information
that we have
into the hands of
scientists and policymakers
that can make a difference.
Earth Engine, the
example here, has
enabled 100,000 plus
scientists throughout the globe
to get a deeper
understanding of our planet.
So there are opportunities
available like this to you
to as a cloud user.
BigQuery in particular has
lots of publicly available
geographic data sets that you
can use and help make better
decisions about our future.
But honestly, the rest is up
to you to take this platform,
to take the data, to take
the partnership that we have
and build for the future.
And I honestly hope you
do, because we've all
seen through the beautiful
very high definition
lens of our next presenter
what's at stake for our planet.
So without further
ado, I'd like to invite
Melissa Wiley from National
Geographic partners
up to the stage.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
Thanks.
MELISSA WILEY: Great.
Thank you, Chris, and thank
you to Google for having me
here today.
So I thought before
I jumped into this
I'd offer you guys a little bit
of inspiration to get started.
I think that's what we do
best at National Geographic
is we inspire people.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- Don't worry.
I'm a professional.
- Photography has the power to--
- Good photography
has the power--
- --Power--
- --the power to undo your
assumptions about the world.
- --Change your
perspective on life--
- --and surprise people with
something that they had no idea
existed.
- --inspire, horrify--
- --stop time for a moment.
- It's an incredible
passport to people's lives.
- Images are so powerful
that they can change
the course of people's lives.
They can change the
course of history.
- Photography can
change the world.
- Never underestimate the
power of a still frame.
- How can we make
the horror that we
see in these pictures stop?
- When people see
those photographs,
I hope that they are overcome
with a sense of urgency.
- I want them to ask
and scream for change.
- --to see that oh that could be
me and make connections between
people.
- It's a universal language.
- --One little hammer.
- --a weapon against
what's wrong out there.
- You have to care.
You really have to care.
It sounds simple but--
I even get emotional sometimes
when I talk about it.
You cannot do superior
work if you're indifferent.
How are you going to do that?
- It's not the
individual photograph,
it's what you do with
it and who you engage
with it makes it powerful.
- While we live in
a world where it's
easy to say that people
don't care anymore,
it's been proven to me time
and again that people do care.
- How could you ever be done?
No, you don't ever
think you're done.
- You just have to do it.
- There's always one more
picture, just one more.
- It takes years of working--
- Just wait a minute, one more--
- --just to hone your vision.
--then I'll be gone.
No I won't.
- If you want to be a
photographer, particularly
a photojournalist, you want
to learn about the world,
and you want to
learn about yourself.
And you want to find things
that you genuinely care about,
because that will be the source
of the greatest work you'll do.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[END PLAYBACK]
MELISSA WILEY: Great.
So I hope everybody
enjoyed that.
My name is Melissa Wiley.
And I am vice president
of digital products
at National Geographic.
And I'm sure as you
can probably all
guess after watching
that video, I've
got just about the
best job in the world.
I get to work with photographers
scientists and explorers who,
just like all of you
who have gathered here,
care deeply about the planet.
And today, I just
want to offer you
a brief glimpse into how we
take our own public message
about creating a
planet in balance,
and we also look at
ourselves inwards
to see how we can
incorporate that message
into our own corporate
responsibility.
So a spirit of exploration
has always really
been at the heart and
soul of everything
we do at National Geographic.
Before there was Pinterest,
Instagram, Facebook,
National Geographic
was really how
we connected the world
to people, cultures,
and critical changes
in the planet.
But now more than ever, we
understand the importance
of using photography and
storytelling helping to inspire
people to take action.
For us, it all starts
with a sense of purpose.
National Geographic believes
that when people understand
about the world around them,
they care deeply about it,
and they want to take
responsibility for it.
On top of our television
and our magazine,
National Geographic reaches
approximately half a billion
people across our
social channels.
And with that scale comes
the opportunities to really
bring communities
together to drive change.
And that's why we
tell the stories
of our photographers
and our scientists
and our explorers who are
documenting our world in order
to inspire everybody here
to go out and make change.
But not only does
National Geographic
have a long history of being a
leader at inspiring all of you,
we've long been a leader
looking inward at ourselves
to understand what actions we
can take towards sustainable
business practices.
So we've adopted a corporate
responsibility policy
that we share with pretty
much everyone we work with.
We share this with
employees, we share it
with vendors, partners,
and all of our suppliers.
So we want to work
towards carbon neutrality.
We're working towards
a zero landfill waste.
We want to practice wise
resource stewardship.
And most importantly,
we really want
to have a healthy and
engaged workforce.
At Nat Geo, we're
committed to operating
are the state our facilities
are sustainably as possible.
Our headquarters in
Washington D.C. First
became LEED certified in 2003.
Through our efforts of tracking
energy, maintenance, waste,
and office supplies, we
were able to increase that
from silver to gold in 2009.
And we actually achieved
our sixth certification
just last year in 2018.
In addition to this great
work, National Geographic
also now receives 50%
our energy from solar.
A few other accomplishments
that we achieved in just 2018,
we earned Energy
Star certifications
for our headquarters.
We've also been going
through a process
to renovate our buildings.
As part of that
renovation, we're
now putting a kitchen on
every floor that offers things
like reusable dishware,
low landfill coffee,
bottle-less water fountains.
As part of our
renovations, we've
been recycling tons
of office furniture,
art supplies, as
well as electronics
and metal from the renovations.
And with that money
that we save, as well as
the proceeds from
our products, we're
then able to reinvest back
into our non-profit arm, who
has awarded over 14,000 grants
so that more curious people
can go out into the world
and inspire all of you
to take action.
Our goal is to identify,
cultivate, and develop
the change makers of
today and tomorrow.
One example of this is our
Planet or Plastic initiative
that we launched in May of 2018.
This is a multi-year effort
about raising awareness
around the global
plastic crisis in order
to help reduce the amount
of single use plastics
that's making it into
the world's oceans.
As part of this initiative,
not only is National Geographic
asking all of you
to go out and take
a look at your own usage of
single use plastic and pledge
to reduce that use, we're
also taking a look inward.
And we have initiated
a plastic audit
across our entire
organization so
that we can understand
the extent of our use
across our supply chain, as well
as work towards eliminating it.
So at National
Geographic, we also
understand the
power of technology
to create connections and drive
empathy and most importantly
increase our awareness and
understanding of one another.
So this is one of
my favorite videos.
What you're taking
a look at here
is an example of our VR
theater that we launched
in October of last year.
So we now have an
Oculus Go headset
that is hooked up to all
400 seats in the room
so that everybody
can have the same 360
experience at the same time.
It's really fun.
However, we realized that not
only do we have the opportunity
and responsibility to
connect our consumer
towards environmental
issues, but we
realize that we
need to take a look
at our internal
infrastructure as well.
So the National Geographic
Image Collection,
the National Geographic
Image Collection
is the record of truth
for all photography
assets at National Geographic.
This database not only holds
the photographs themselves,
but it holds information about
contracts, rights, and actually
the physical location.
So if you want to go
down and actually find
that original Afghan
girl print, you're
going to take a look in
the Image Collection,
and that's going to tell you
where to go and actually pull
that print off the shelves.
Last year, we found
ourselves in a situation
where that system had
to be taken offline.
And while that was
extremely-- and extremely
is an understatement.
It was extremely
inconvenient for everyone
who uses the system, it
gave us an opportunity
to take a step back
and really take
a look at that
20-year-old system
and make some critical
decisions about how we
wanted to move forward with it.
As a result, we decided
to partner with Google.
We know that Google
shares similar passions
as National Geographic
around sustainability.
The actions that took this
system offline unfortunately
really didn't earn
us a lot of goodwill
with our photographers.
And we knew that
the steps that we
took to bring the
system back online,
we really wanted
to be able to say
that we were storing their
photographs as sustainably
as possible.
We wanted to be able to
prove to our photographers
that we recognized the
importance of their collections
and that we share
common values with them.
So we partnered with Google,
and we moved this system
to the cloud in just
over two months.
So this was an exciting
process for us.
And it's really been a
huge success story for us
to bring this back online.
We're now in the process
of partnering with Google
to really try and understand
those energy savings that we
took when we migrated this
system from our on premise
facility into the cloud.
So we've been able
to provide Google
with a bunch of statistics
about our legacy system.
And then Google is
helping us to calculate
that to really understand what
savings that we've earned.
So this study is still ongoing.
We're just starting to get
in some early learnings.
But some of the things
that we are seeing
is that we are going to
incur greenhouse emissions
savings over the course of a
year that equal around heating
an average sized home
for about 30 to 40 months
or driving a car for
about 25,000 miles.
And those stats
are exciting to us.
They are relatively small,
but the Image Collection, it
is also a very small portion
of our overall infrastructure.
And we feel like this is
going to make a great case
study for us to then
go to our executives
and say that we think
sustainability needs
to be part of our benchmarks
in all of our infrastructure
planning.
It's going to help get
us towards that carbon
neutral goal that we
talked about earlier.
So that's just a brief look.
Going to now hand
this over to Jake.
I've talked to you
a lot about the work
National Geographic has done
to look at our own corporation.
Jake is going to come up
here and talk about products
that you all can use to take
a look at your own footprint.
[APPLAUSE]
JAKE WACHMAN: Hi, everyone.
I'm Jake Wachman.
I run software product and
engineering for SunPower.
And if you're not familiar with
SunPower, maybe if you are,
you may know that we make
the world's most efficient
solar cells and panels.
And we offer those all
around the world to customers
everywhere, as well as in
the US where we packaged them
as solutions for residential
and commercial customers.
And so it's my team's job to
make our software at SunPower
as amazing as our hardware.
We're here today to talk
about a new technology we've
built on top of Google Cloud
that we think does that.
But first, let's talk hardware.
So this is the
SolarStratos plane
that will soar to 80,000 feet
into the stratosphere powered
just on solar
cells, specifically
SunPower solar cells.
Why?
Because our cells are
up to 22.7% efficient.
And that's exactly the
kind of power output
you need when you have a
limited wingspan with which
to power a plane.
This plane and this team
prove that solar's here,
it's ready now, it's ready for
the most difficult applications
you can throw at it,
and it's powerful.
It's also powerful
enough for Google,
or rather Google and Alphabet's
spin-out, Project Loon.
Project Loon, if
you're not aware,
sends balloons aloft
for months on end
to provide internet service
to remote parts of the world.
And you can see down
here, it's running
on SunPower solar panels
in very low temperatures
all times of the day.
And those are the
very same cells
that go on homeowners'
roofs here in the US
and around the world.
You see them up
there, kind of looks
like a skylight we've made
10 gigawatts of solar power
since our first factory opened.
That's equivalent to offsetting
40 million metric tons
of carbon dioxide or roughly
taking 9 million cars
off the road for a year.
That's a lot of solar.
But even as solar has taken
off, we've only reached about 3%
of American homes.
So we have 97% percent to go.
And I think that we have two
big problems that we need
to solve to get to that 100%.
First, I'd say we have
an awareness problem.
Homeowners and
businesses don't realize
the extent to which solar
can save them money,
can help the environment, and
also, decentralized energy
can provide a degree
of energy independence.
And secondly, we have
a workflow problem.
Getting that solar panel on the
roof and getting it designed
and getting installed is
actually a very difficult thing
to solve.
And so we try to solve
both with software.
We want to make solar as
easy to buy and install
as any other
consumer electronics.
So who here remembers
televisions?
Raise your hand.
Yeah, not quite a relic
of the past yet, right?
But buying a TV's pretty
simple and pretty easy.
They come some pretty
standard sizes, right?
You got 65 inches, 55 inches,
all the way down to 32.
And so when you're going
through the process of buying
a television as a
consumer, you think,
I have a wall I have a
credenza, I have a media center,
does the TV fit?
Can I see it from my couch?
It's pretty simple,
understanding
what size of television,
how much TV you need.
Well, solar is not that simple.
Every house is different,
every roof unique.
We're pointed in
orientation toward the sun
in different ways.
There are pipes and
chimneys you can't see here
in this simplified diagram.
And it becomes a
very complex process.
It becomes a custom widget
for every homeowner.
And so that's our challenge.
How do we simplify that?
And I'll show you
the state of the art.
I'll show you how we
actually quote today.
The quote is so important
to understanding the value
proposition to the homeowner and
to providing them an accurate
estimate of how much
energy they'll save
and how much money they'll save.
And so here's how
we do it today.
We take a look at the roof.
This is actually
deceptively complex.
And we say, OK, there's
a chimney down there,
there are five skylights,
can't put solar there.
And I don't know if you
see this right there,
but those are little pipes.
They're really hard
to see, actually
hard for our design team to see.
They're about nine of
them, at least nine
of them that I can
see with my naked eye.
But that's not all.
There's also local
jurisdictions.
And you have to take
those into account
as you're designing a
solar power system as well.
And so most towns and
cities and counties
require walkways
along the ridge line
and along the front
and back of the house
so you can actually access
the roof at any time.
And so it gets
even more complex.
There are trees and bushes
all around the house.
And those are shading the house.
So it's hard to know
where exactly should I
put those solar panels and
how tall are these trees,
because this isn't just a
two dimensional problem.
This is a three
dimensional problem.
This house actually
happens to be on a hill.
And the trees, some are
higher, some are lower.
You can't tell that from
the overhead view alone.
And so our designers
spend 30 minutes
per house thousands
of times a week
to generate a solar design.
And I'll show you a sped
up video of how that works,
here it is.
They're outlining the roof.
This is the current state
of the art sped up 50x.
This is what they do
2,000 times a week
to generate solar designs
for our customers--
making sure all the roof
planes are in the right spot,
putting in those walkways
getting the roof plane
just right, putting
in more walkways--
so we're about five
minutes in right now--
getting the pipes
and the skylights.
So there are 100 million future
solar homes the United States.
At our current pace,
it would take us
a century to design them all.
Who has time for that?
I don't have time for
that, the planet certainly
doesn't have time for that.
So there must be a better way.
And we are here today to talk
about it and announce it.
We call it SunPower
Instant Design.
And it's built on Google Cloud.
A homeowner enters an
address and within 60 seconds
gets a design back.
We're using all the
best machine learning
that Google Cloud has to
offer and running it on GPUs.
I'll get a little bit more
into how we're doing it,
but we're very
excited about this.
We think this will change
how people go solar.
So here's how we're doing it.
We're taking SunPower's years of
design expertise, the hundreds
of thousands of
solar designs we've
created, along with our
world class sales platform
that we use today, called EDDiE.
And we're mashing it together
with what Google brings
to the table, which is GCP,
which as you heard is a zero
carbon emission platform-- which
is great we got zero carbon
emission making more
zero carbon emissions--
as well as Google
Maps and sunroof data.
Google has great
imagery of the world.
And we use that as our raw
data to make this all happen.
Let's go a little deeper.
Let's go deeper under the hood.
So SunPower has those
hundreds of thousands
of designs per year,
Google has the raw data.
We train a model and
annotate roofs, put them
in a Cloud Storage bucket, train
the model in Cloud ML Engine.
And then every time a
homeowner enters an address,
we run it through that
engine to detect the roof
and look for the
abstractions, basically
just what you saw before that
we did manually 2,000 times
a week.
Then once we have the
environment characterized,
we lay out the solar panels,
we do a shade analysis,
we create an energy estimate
and then out pops the design.
That actually is a
computer generated design.
So I'll show you Instant Design.
Now, I have to say
we're a little scared
of the curse of the live
demos, so this a video.
It's actually at real
time, not sped up.
But you can go check it out for
yourself, the working software,
all the way over
there at the Industry
Pavilion where we'll have
people to demo it all week.
So here it is.
And this is a test environment.
This isn't really what
the homeowner would see.
But we've got the
technology up and working.
We're pretty
excited to share it.
Homeowner enters an address,
our favorite test house,
clicks Create Design.
We're doing all the same
stuff you saw before.
This is, however, in real
time-- outlining the roof,
looking for the abstractions,
looking for the trees,
laying out the panels,
figuring out the shade, which
then lets us get to the energy.
And then 60 seconds
later, we get a design.
So it might be a
little bit of a way.
Actually, it's faster than that.
That's real time.
That's about 17 seconds
for that particular house.
And you can see it is in 3D.
Well, maybe I'll show
it one more time.
So it actually
takes almost as long
to enter the address
as it does to run this.
And we're very fortunate
to be using Platform
that lets us go really fast.
I've never appreciated
GPUs as much as I do today
and how fast they
can actually process
all this very intensive
data really quickly
to get answers for
homeowners fast.
So you see the 3D model there.
We have all the abstractions.
And then we have the
energy data, as well as
much more behind that.
So let me show you--
these are all designs made
within Instant Design.
These are all
computer generated,
no human involved whatsoever.
And you'll notice that
they're not perfect.
A couple of panels
might be askew,
or we might be missing a
spot where we could place
another couple, and that's OK.
As we do this more and as
we train the model more,
it will only get stronger.
You'll also notice, if
you're an expert in solar,
that we have panels on the
north side of the roof we,
have some panels
facing northeast.
We've got a lot of
panels everywhere.
And that's also
intentional, because we
want to give
homeowners the choice
to choose the aesthetic
and also system size that
meets their energy needs.
They get to down select from
these what we call maximum fit
design, because some
homeowners may want solar
on the back of their house.
If it were me, I'd
want it on the front,
be really proud about
it on my own house.
Some homeowners
only need SunPower
solar a little bit of it,
because they have a very energy
efficient house.
And then some homeowners
need a lot of solar,
because they've got an
EV, TVs, pool, et cetera,
and they need to run a lot of
energy through their house.
So let's zoom up.
This is why we're doing this.
If Google wants a cloud computer
in every hand or on every desk,
SunPower is interested
in solar on every roof.
And to me,
applications like this
to better the human
condition and our health
and the health of
our environment
are really the best uses
of machine learning.
So we see SunPower
Instant Design
as an early example
of everything
that we can do to move the
planet and the environment
forward.
I also think it's one of
the finer examples of what
we can do with GPUs.
So imagine if we
took all those GPUs
currently binding for
Bitcoin and redirected them
to mine for solar in the cloud.
Could we design
all those hundreds
million future solar
homes in an afternoon?
Potentially.
So we're very excited
to launch this.
It's arriving this summer.
And people in select California
cities can go to our website
and enter in their
address and then get
a solar design for their home.
Until then, go to
sunpower.com/design to learn
more and to find out when
it's coming to your area.
And of course, for everyone
here in the audience
and at the expo, you can go
actually check it out yourself
at the SunPower booth
in the energy section.
Very excited to launch
this, and thank you everyone
for coming to our talk.
The three of us will be
around after for questions.
And then I was told also
to move one forward ahead
to say complete the survey.
So thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]